alright this is a walkthrough tutorial
for Diamond digger saga level 170 this
one the top four levels in the game
right now and the main problem is the
third room if you don't have enough
moves when you get to it or enough
points then you won't be able to finish
off the level so in the beginning you
want to you want to remove some of the
same blocks in the middle if you get
chances to match make matches that will
hit two or more of them at the same time
that's good but as you can see a lot of
times you won't get that so you just
want to set things up so that you can
get out of this room with a lot of moves
left and be able to get about at least
10,000 excuse me at least 10,000 points
before you leave so there's quite a few
colors on this on this level so are me
on this board so it's you know it's
tough to actually make the right matches
we can you know we clear out the water
so it's it's coming through and clear
out the door when we don't have good
ones and then like now we have a couple
that are advanced a bit so we want to
try to make matches next to them
and we could use our rechargeable
booster here because it'll it'll charge
up pretty fast and so we got through
with 15,000 points in 26 move so that's
pretty good we did use the booster that
so we need to charge that up pretty
quickly in this room I mean here you
want to make matches that will hit two
or more face are singing blocks at the
same time so we're just kind of be
matches over here at first
and pick up the quick points that you
get for the 3,000 matches for the ones
that are eight of them around so now we
want to kind of open the door and then
get through we have a decent amount of
points that we're starting to run low
and move so so now we'll just make
masses over here open the door no we are
not have to pretty much get a perfect
room in the third room with only 15
moves and that doesn't happen very often
because there's a lot of color so we'll
just see how it goes you want to work
from the top when you can just because
that gives you a better chance of you
have to clear all these outlier in here
and that gives you a better chance to
move through without wasting two mins
all right so we're going to use the
color burst for the Reds to clear out
this area down here we got most of the
faces going now the same blocks and now
we're going to try to get the water out
so we have 73 73 thousand points and
nine moves that's not great but if we
could actually get through this if we
get a pretty good setup in here which we
haven't so far so we'll just see where
we're going to go how to make moves at
the bottom at first and that's what we
want us to get like two of these at the
same time we have a 3,000 points so we
have to actually match like 90 so it's
not looking good right now we'll see
what happens all right so now we have a
color color burst and we're pretty close
to the point so we want to match this
with one of these that could possibly
give us the chance to get will have
95,000 so we'll need a match with two on
the next one so it looks like the blue
might give a sort of chance to get two
greens at the same time so we'll go
ahead and match that and then hope that
the green fall and they did so that's
how you do it it's not always going to
work out but you know if you keep those
kinds of things in mind as you move
through your be able to beat it
eventually so I hope that helps leave a
comment if you have any questions and
remember to like the video if you found
it helpful thanks